it's how to get rid of that black porn
with some drawing chances I guess if you
do that um so we might have the same
thing here he's throwing in a check
first and he's okay
okay now we get this weird ending
we did not predict I was saying this is
winning for Magnus this is winning for
Magnus here you can win the white Rook
you could have look at Magnus what is
this he just realized he could have won
the white Rook The Black Queen could
have gone to the B3 Square check the
white king Winnie the white game over
suddenly is still winning but he has to
work hard again he has to win it all
over again back to square one what
I mean that's maybe not the most obvious
opportunity taking that point As Natural
but yeah he realized as soon as he
played the move yeah it's like you said
Ivanka when you play a move and you know
you miss the you just missed the really
simple winning move and there is the way
I mean the way you try to draw it is
it's just if you've got the minor pieces
which is white and I mean the mighty
pieces of the rook and the night you
just got to make sure they're close to
each other